you
okay we are about to start an hourly
bullet arena all right for a second I
thought I was gonna get paired up with
Tampa chest but oh I didn't mean to do
that someone said is this gonna be a
blunder mifflin type tournament so far
it's been a mouse slip type aha I get to
break down their Center I'd like that I
get to take here with tempo let's hang
on to that Pawnee is important and we're
gonna look for a rook here and then a d5
push hop in here extend my bishop Queen
trade mm-hmm I don't know I went piled
on a take actually I could take on c3 of
b3 just looking for B form mm-hmm what
do I do
I guess I'll take back up my bishop does
well to offset this tonight he's a
strong piece let's keep going when I get
at c3 my knight is within checking
distance let's take on this rook maybe
yikes this was a bad idea I think uh-huh
aren't they plundering here on the rook
let's take that okay I think this is
working out now and then I can move my
clean here and then King in the corner
whoa
scary that was pretty scary let's just
get some air
okay now we have everything under
control up a rook let's just function on
the dark squares take here no stalemates
no stalemates oh they resigned oh that's
why there was a some silence there I
wasn't sure what happened that was the
problem
it wasn't an audio issue it's just I was
stunned I was stunned I go quiet when
I'm stunned watch out for that all right
let's be a space space invader mode
let's avoid the exchange play with some
space and have black hopefully struggle
to find good pieces good squares for
their pieces uh-huh
opportunity to jump into that hole
Knight d5 ooh this is looking juicy 97
if Queen takes pawn maybe that was their
best try cuz now I'm getting a just
queen oh no I got to get that off as
soon as possible as soon as possible I
guess we'll just take their yeah I
definitely need to get the automatic
Queen thing going on let's just take
keep it real simple return the knight
just stop the rook from getting active
I'm fine if they want to take their and
gets just double up and then get to the
seventh wild pigs and they're ready I'm
fine with that and just Bishop
back actually I have the time in this
game that mean where's the move maybe I
don't have the time maybe this was a bad
idea
oh no I can't get back to the game are
you kidding me I can't get back to the
game that was not a good idea
ah what did I just do that was a very
bad idea
ah man and I withdrew yeah you have the
time you have the time oh that was just
awful I tried to avoid disaster and I
simply create a disaster never do that
again
I have to ec and it's tough streaming
it's tough being a streamer you think
you have everything all squared away you
know have you updated this site do you
have you know the audio work in this
that and the other and then you find out
you don't have always uh pre moved to or
always promote to a queen on there's
always something isn't there ah man
alright I got a fight back
I got a fight back we're gonna play on
the h-file you could do it you could do
it that one stung man that one stung
we're gonna crack open this position
fish up here this is looking juicy this
is looking real juicy get the Queen
there we go
now we're cooking they resigned back
determine how we doing twenty six ninety
players are in ah okay
you gotta fight back you gotta fight
back
alright let's throw the Sicilian at
white maybe even go fishing some huh
it's been a while alrighty let's pin the
night and look for d5 all right let's
take take once and then cows all they
would take on g7 if I took the EEP on my
queen is unprotected alright
hmm I think I could do this on Bishop f4
I could return the knight here a little
scary
alright let's get this in still do this
anticipating g5 ah that wasn't a good
move yeah that was silly our dark square
Bishop is a really strong piece hmm it's
a bit scary I must say a bit scary uh
yeah not liking this position at all
rook h7 would have been a good move okay
don't like doing that are we doing on
the clock not good not good at all
they went into the think tank a little
bit there it's gonna pre move in scoop
up that pond I'll go for hmm let's see
rook here to defend some G the g7 square
14 seconds I fought back on the clock
I'm not sure how I managed that give him
a kick and then get pushing this guy
he's past ooh that was actually a
blunder on my part huh stay focused now
stay focused man stay focused don't try
to go into your settings or anything man
okay how are we doing how many points do
we have not enough John Madden's in
first but he has he hit a speed bump
there he doesn't have the fire that's
nice no fire for John Madden
alright let's come over here maybe look
for 94 pile up on that pinned piece see
how they like that let's keep going yeah
I was ready to drop my knight I need
four let's take no it's anchored that
night in there I can't rely upon well
actually that was fine I still it upon
to watch over my knight I have some
serious dark square weaknesses um let's
go here maybe I could make some magic
happen with that knight on e4 on the f2
Square Queen and Knight something here
maybe g5 and then push mm I guess we'll
go here I'm not sure what to do
trade LightSquared bishop smae be hmm
not playing this well that I'll take
with the pawn down a few seconds here
they are yeah this is gonna be another
rat race bishop incoming right here I
got to get my Bishop doing something
else you know only one open file let's
go here first don't pin me hope just a
little hope chest right there
little hope just alright we're gonna
come back Queen takes pawn is there
alright they could take on g7 right now
I don't have any time I'm never gonna
see that sneaky pawn never oh I still
have that on it's gonna come back to
bite me now go for it go for it right
now this is the moment where is it now
where is it always I don't even know
where it is no no no no I gotta make a
move that's when I should have done it I
forgot that you have a few seconds
before the game starts good grief it's
gonna come back to bite me again
Oh alrighty let's got Queenie to maybe
look for a queenside castle huh two
birds with one stone
King safety maybe rook activity on the D
file I guess Knight f6 we're gonna throw
the Jeep on at him see our reacts move
forward uh-huh-huh b6 is a weakness
alright let's break open this
I want a 5 let's jump in there maybe h4
he really can't be tolerated
FML slip wow they are really greedy
they're really greedy how dare you do
that
grab that deep on I should have much
earlier just taken here took here before
Bishop to f6 got back rank issues how
they solving that bit should be seven
eventually what can I do
I could give a check how they're gonna
block with the rook they have that they
missed it thought all righty oh just
want to secure my king some maybe b4 I'd
like to get my other rook there let's
scoop this guy up and take take that one
as well I have pressure on this pond so
no I missed that
fifteen seconds push the past fun all
right
and get this in I'm getting a queen
whit's check I guess King up Queen here
let's check in where's the mate
that's gonna do it back to tournament
where is this thing I can't find it by
going right by it
game behavior man game behavior always
man always promote to Queen
am I still in yes waiting to be paired
up
I didn't withdraw yeah you know now you
know what's gonna happen
stay tuned because with my luck there's
gonna be a position where I'm gonna need
to promote to a knight wait you just
wait for it yeah there's gonna be a
position where I need to promote to like
a knight a bishop or a rook anything but
a queen wait for it it's coming soon
all right well she can't feel too
comfortable can she got the rook you got
the rook opposite the Queen that'll go
here I could have maybe taken on a d5
Wow
really that's a wild queen man she's
gone too far Knight takes bishop is
needed oh they had that move and then
the Queen had some third rank squares no
all right how are we looking here we got
18 we're still in this ooh actually this
is a 25 minute sir our 26 minute
chairman a little quicker more use a
little bit more used to the 30 minute
ones okay why am I going with English
stuff some space
not quite mm-hmm pressure on that night
all right I guess I'm gonna win some
material I know I'll get that guy back
huh let's take care Wow Oh just develop
it's not a problem and definitely want a
castle before Bishop a6 exactly that
would have been the no soup for you move
couldn't counsel through check of course
for Queen trade I am up a pond ah that's
a good move does this work hmm still up
a pond I have some loose pieces mm-hmm
all right they're in a pin now how do
you get out of that Bishop takes Bishop
be fine and get to recapture and then
hit the pinch piece all right
just want some flight square I guess
here put them in another pin and just
take with the night it's otherwise
there's rook check mm-hmm I guess here
to defend they're gonna win that night
yeah I guess they're gonna win that
night oh and I think they would take the
rook if I took on e - that wasn't a good
idea
let's get that Queen out of there huh
just want to Queen trade Queen f4 I
don't care if my pawns are split like
this trades give me the trades push
these guys I don't have much time time
burner and they're down a time all right
25 25 23 22 whoo all right oh let's try
efore and drop your you pawn who cares
about him right who needs an e pawn
awful all right we're gonna we're gonna
scoop up the light square bishop but
maybe make them struggle Oh like in this
mm-hmm
in-betweener Knight takes Knight I take
on g6 now we're cooking we are really
cooking on the light squares I'll scoop
him up track down that rook why not you
don't have a good reason not to do that
let's just make sure f2 is secure oh
well I saved the rook but I just wanted
to stop there there tricks on f2 hitting
h7 mm-hmm
just castle take this pawn oh yeah let's
do that
jeez six Queen h7 now we're getting mate
has a pretty quick one back to
tournament 29 29 26 I'm on fire so too
are these top guys here the inter in
Tampa chess less than eight ooh this is
of course a big one got a fly Sarla
Cairo Adam get the Queen hmm let's come
all the way back and claim some success
I induced f3 throw the H pawn ah yeah
right stay on that diagonal hmm
interesting
all righty
uh I'm gonna go with the sack in this
push here hmm Wow they went with that
let's take here first and I got to
overprotect
this square I may want to just castle
before it's too late
ship g5 is a little annoying I was
thinking about going Queen side but this
should be fine though mm-hm
Bishop f5 yeah so they're gonna get a
pawn back bye huh oh they got some
pretty nasty stuff lined up here well I
chewed up a lot of time right there not
sure what I should do I'm gonna get
mated real soon okay yeah this is really
scary I got to get rid of that all right
where bishop was just too good i don't
have much time either coming Chuck all
right maybe I could start throwing in
some checks I'm gonna grab that pawn
with check now mm-hmm can I get anything
going against their king you're getting
mated I love that Wow all right straight
out of left field right there I made out
of nowhere I'll take it what a lucky dog
you are 33 31 30 less than six minutes
to go man
ah was I on the ropes or was I on the
ropes
big time go play the lottery straight
after this game this tournament you
really need to just go play the lottery
where's the Powerball and what is it up
to all right
let's hunt down that dark square bishop
got him he's all mine and my phone is
ready to land a fork mmm
all right let's let's castle I have it
ooh they just opened up that diagonal
for my bishop now let's see if they bite
take him take the beep on I want the bee
file all right now we're gonna crack
open oh they're really helping me out
we're looking for a quick mate against
their King opposite sides castle oh no
boy
that Knight is really having a tough day
at the office
it takes c3 they might resign of all
these pieces working on getting the
Queen maybe there was something better
they resigned back to terment pretty
quick win 35:34 I have fire and so does
the leader John Madden who I am now
paired up with let's go with this and
get some space yeah let's do this let's
see how they play with this space
disadvantage mm-hmm sneaky all right I'm
winning upon here huh um let's go Queen
side just pack up I want to keep this
bishop in a pin dropping c4 how are they
getting out of that pin though we're
gonna find out
take that night night f5 is a threat
winning a piece mm-hmm go here Bishop
takes Knight Queen check I have as well
I feel like I'm thinking very clearly in
this tournament okay that's a pin Pig
crashing through on g7 probably resign
right around here it's leading to mate
back to tournament a big win
that was the pack leader less than 3 38
35 34 okay
c5 smith mora they throw the smith more
at me I'll go fishing here a little bit
Knight b5 let's go let's go there
Bishop h4 to g3 is probably fine let's
see if they take them stay on that
diagonal I need to do this I'm not a
knight in the bishop now mm-hmm
all right there night I have the H file
let's keep pressure on there Knight
Queen h7 maybe if they move their F pawn
hmm isn't this trapping their night
let's try it
out there nights cooked I don't know
take towards the center I could have
taken with the pawn let's take the
knight and weather the storm
let's give a check and then Bishop here
if the requestor block I have g3 hmmm
queenside castle yes just front ooh but
I have this and alright take my pawn so
like a queenside castle that's my idea
here they're gonna insert a check it's a
good move alright let's pile up on that
pinned piece though Queens are gonna be
traded now let's just make it really
simple normally I would not want to take
that pinned piece so quick but not
looking too good on the clock here no
clock advantage gotta kick it into a
higher gear Bishop you need to do
something better and it throws some
checks in have that pawn up here push
this guy just track him down I need some
time burners wow that was a really bad
cream of art back to tournament mana oh
that's gonna do it I don't think I'm
gonna get paired up and I have a
six-point lead 42 36 I think that's
gonna do it
oh man that was a pretty ugly tournament
oh not happy at all with how I played
and who that's had to fight back there
going into my settings trying to change
the promotion thing whoo alright we had
I got first dwarf man to John Madden 3
117 at the end or in this one the inter
Aerodactyl Tampa chess oh man
lucky lucky lucky I was in this game oh
okay to the 117 of you that took part in
the hourly bullet arena good games all
alright
you